il y a pas de secret dans la ville de
New York il y a des caméras partout des
relevés téléphoniques des tickets de
parking
quelqu'un a forcément vu ou entendu
quelque chose
la ville est au courant de tout
tu as
pour la faire courte c'est ma meilleure
amie
on va trouver qui lui a fait ça si on
arrive à trouver qui est en lien avec
Samantha
on trouvera qui a tiré
de lieutenant de police sont venus ici
tu étais où le 4 juillet
[Musique]
je sais pas comment je sais pas pourquoi
mais cette fille est liane
vous savez pourquoi elle est allée à
l'autre bout de la ville où quelqu'un
lui a tiré dessus ça m'était l'une des
nôtres et ben je sais pas ce que ça me
savait mais je veux savoir
elle m'a laissé des indices elle était
sur une piste je pensais que le seul à
pouvoir découvrir laquelle je dois en
apprendre plus sur ces gens
ils ont de l'argent pour plusieurs
générations il cache quelque chose
quand on a commencé cette révolution
avec elle aurait des conséquences